Jellyfish's topology is what is called a random regular graph.
It's random because each graph is uniformly selected
at random from the set of all regular graphs. A regular
graph is simply one where each node has the same degree. And a graph in
Jellyfish is one where the switches in
the topology are the nodes. In contrast to
the earlier data center topology diagram we saw, here is a picture of a
Jellyfish random graph with 432 servers and 180 switches. Every node in this
graph has a fixed degree of 12. Jellyfish's approach is to construct
a random graph at the Top of Rack switch layer. Every Top of Rack switch i,
has some total number of Ki ports, of which it uses Ri
to connect to other Top of Rack switches. The remaining Ki minus Ri
ports are used to connect servers. With n racks,
the network then supports n times Ki minus Ri
servers. And the network is a random regular graph
denoted as follows. Formally, random regular graphs are sampled
uniformly from the space of all R regular graphs. Achieving such a property is
a complex graph theory problem, but there's a simple procedure that produces a
sufficiently uniform random graph that empirically have the desired properties.